[Music]
what's shake and reject nation it's your
boy John coming at you
gonna check out some more music today I
was cruising the trending page and I
found out that there is a new Muse song
out that's pretty exciting to me muse is
a band I used to love a lot and in
recent times have kind of fallen out of
sync with something about the way that
Matt Bellamy's writing has changed that
just doesn't grab me so much anymore I
feel like he used to write songs feel
like he used to utilize a certain
element of poetry and and these days I
feel like he just tells me stuff about
his philosophies through his music which
is fine it just doesn't appeal to me as
much like the songs don't feel quite as
much like songs to me dig down came out
like last year or something came out a
while ago the music video is cool the
song overall I thought was alright I
haven't really been compelled to go back
and listen to it certainly not as much
as some of their older stuff which I
always feel bad being that guy but it's
been since about the resistance and
really probably more like black holes
and revelations that I've really been
enthralled and enamoured I like some
stuff off the second law and and
definitely I think the resistance
there's a lot of good stuff on the album
too I don't know I guess I just kind of
miss something that used to be a part of
Muse but who knows man maybe this new
song will be more up my alley I'm always
interested to hear what they're up to I
think they're all very talented at what
they do Tom Howard is an amazing drummer
Chris Wolstenholme is great of that bass
and Matt Bellamy I mean you know that
dude's just a prodigy of guitar piano
vocals well what have you I feel like
between those three there's always gonna
be something worth checking out maybe
this song will be that and as always we
cannot show the full song on YouTube I
apologize to you for that if I didn't
have to cut it up I wouldn't but I do so
I will but if you want to see the full
thing the unadulterated uncut version of
this reaction and review head on over to
our patreon check us out over there
we've got a whole bunch of exclusive
content flaying full-length music videos
full like TV shows Q&A other exclusive
videos behind-the-scenes stuff a ton of
great people we're having a lot of fun
over there so come check us out so
without further ado
this is called thought contagion here we
go
[Music]
ass-kickings
[Music]
[Music]
Phantom
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like a hungry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thriller
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay I you know on first impression
that was pretty fun that was pretty fun
ah this is the eighties eighties dist
algebra we're all about that right now
and AI mean it's a cool look for sure I
like all the video glitches and stuff
and you know the little references I
like this motif they have going that all
these songs are like their own video
game console and you know the Lighting's
really cool the visuals are really cool
even though I'm you know kind of getting
worn out on eighties nostalgia they
certainly took a lot of cool stuff for
this video I like their little title
cards they did their tribute to thriller
and that's you know that's pretty cool
as a song I think this appealed to me a
little bit more I mean I get what
they're getting at you know the idea of
the thoughts kind of as viruses almost
thought contagion spreading of toxic
thoughts or ideas and comparing those
two you know kind of being changed by a
vampire or something like that likening
those to something parasitic something
viral and that's very now it's very
fitting in the age of fake news and just
the general cult of opinion cult of self
all sorts of things really yeah I mean
you know it's a nifty little metaphor
that plays out in this video I like that
you get these like Resident Evil hunk
dudes showing up to do the dance to and
this whole idea that our protagonist
here is becoming a robot because of the
ideas he's been bitten and inflicted
with and you know I like the vampire
motif both in the video and as it
pertains to the song this was again Ike
I sort of brought up a bulk at the front
of the video about how I don't feel like
Matt Bellamy as much writes lyrics
poetically or with as much metaphor as
he used to and this kind of split that
difference for me it's like I get what
he's getting at I get the real-world
parts of it kinda jumps back and forth
between some more poetic imagery and
then you know the the point the specific
thing he's talking about oh yeah this
got me a little more excited about the
upcoming album I guess this song is sort
of regarded as the sequel to fury which
was I believe the b-side to sing for
absolution so you know that's kind of
cool if you're into the lore of Muse
overall I'm curious to hear what this
album's gonna be
like I mean I'm not champing at the bit
for it per se but this hinted at some
cool sounds I like that this song has a
creepy vibe too especially in some of
those weird synth sounds I like the way
he's playing those high hats I mean
generally the the drums and the bass the
rhythm section of this song I thought
was pretty cool and I like that choice
especially the verses to go with this
kind of rolling bass tone and then all
this kind of skinny hi-hat stuff that
was kind of cool you know bring up the
rhythm section a bit the pre-chorus the
pre-hook whatever you call that the
whole you've been bitten by a true
believer someone hungrier than you
I like that passage of the song for sure
and I just I don't know I have a soft
spot in my heart I guess for the weird
like street trash gutter Punk aesthetic
not so much the 80s vibe like for me
eighties nostalgia like is cool I
appreciate it sometimes but I'm not
nostalgic for that so this current wave
is just something I'm sort of looking at
more than connecting to but a facet of
that that I do kind of get a kick out of
is like I said that Street trash gutter
Punk just like Wild West inner-city sort
of thing I thought this was a pretty
nifty music video overall I like the
different parts of this song alright I
like where it goes the hooks are kind of
catchy compared to some of their other
songs especially some of the other
singles it's not overly flashy so to
speak
I think the rhythm section shines and
that's a cool thing and I like the sort
of layered pianos and guitars and stuff
like that it kind of reminds me of older
Musil bit and the parts of the song are
pretty cool I think it's pretty catchy I
like the creepiness of the sound and
combined with this music video I think
everything does come together in a
pretty cool way I guess it's kind of fun
to hear mutant kind of vocalized melody
that uh underneath the chorus itself you
know kind of reminded me of some other
bands by the end I like that our
protagonist is like becoming a robot and
game over you shouldn't have succumbed
to those bad thoughts man now you're
trapped in the game forever and both
Matt Bellamy at the end of showing up
werewolf style you know it's a nice
little touch I like his jacket so yeah
it was a pretty cool music video isn't a
pretty cool song I'll definitely keep an
eye out for muses new album but until
that point what did you guys think are
you all about this song or you met about
a do you hate it let me know in the
comments and as always you can subscribe
to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get updated every time a review or a
video is out and come check us out on
patreon and there's a link to the
Stardust app in the description box
follow us first over there talking about
movies and stuff a lot of fun and as
always guys Cheers